is there anyone who's done something
quite different with the role of horeb
who appears quite different and yet in
your mind you for that well that's not
how I saw it
but maybe even prefer it well there are
certainly a number actors who are you
know the the show character differs from
the book character hmm some of that is
due to the way the actors portraying
them and some of his due to the script
changes yeah and the way David and Dan
and the other writers including myself
are writing some of those those parts I
think the show's version of Renly is
somewhat different than my version of
Renly probably the one that was most
striking was Nathalia tena as the
character of OSHA hmm from the time I
met her first time last night she's here
as she came up and right as Matt's but
grain is she's she's wonderful yes and
her OSHA is actually a former
interesting character than my OSHA yeah
you know the character in the book
fulfills a certain function but never
memorize door what made you just want to
you know watch this character and learn
more about this character and see more
scenes with this character the way that
the way that Natalia does when she plays
that role on screen so if I when I bring
OSHA back in the future books I'm
probably gonna have to make her more
interesting do you think when the TV
show deviates from the books you think
your fans think that's a personal insult
to you and your work well I I think
there are a lot of fans and you get all
ends of the spectrum there are some who
understand it perfectly well yeah but
they're they're always the purists who
react very negatively to to any
deviation from from the text
and that you know in some ways I have a
certain affection for the purist because
I their passion and love for the books
is is unquestioned yeah but some of them
do get a little obsessive about it I
mean I was talking at dinner last night
with milto's who played serial Pharrell
yeah yeah and we were talking about how
a certain element of the fan base went
crazy when he was cast because he has
air and cereal is is bald and in the
books it is there was a plot point that
turned on the necessity of his bald yeah
yeah so you know I mean that kind of
changes is incidental so because we
never actually see him dying would you
bring him back for me because I loved
him so much there must be a mechanism to
bring him back I'll take that under
consideration and the final thing that I
must ask you about him here in the UK it
is illegal to support both Manchester
United and Manchester City and yet you
are a fan of both the New York Jets and
the Giants how can you justify that my
extreme age yeah I was born and grew up
as a fan of the New York Football Giants
in the 50s they were did New York's team
in the National Football League the NFL
but in the early 60s a new league
started the American Football League the
AFL yeah we're completely unconnected
with the NFL they were a rival league
that never played each other and the New
York team which initially was called the
Titans and I didn't care much about them
but then they changed it into the Jets
and they got this quarterback out of
Alabama named named Joe Namath Broadway
Joe
you know young long-haired quarterback
wore mink coats on the sidelines and you
know he was a very appealing figure so I
started following the AFL as well as the
NFL and rooting for for Broadway Joe
wouldn't you know and I had two teams I
had one team in the NFL and I had one
team in the AFL that was fine but then
the two leagues merged so what was the
other dewdrop one team or another you
know I couldn't do that I love them both
so I do have for my moments of you know
when they play each other yeah where's
your allegiance I'd yeah I just root for
a good game with no injuries yeah very
diplomatic well thank you so much for
talking to us my pleasure thank you